This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The only truly accurate map of the world would be a map the size of the world. So if you want to make a map useful something that you can hold in your hands, you have to start making choices. You have to choose what information you're interested in and what you're throwing out. These choices influence how the person reading the map views the world. But a map's influence doesn't end there. Maps can actually shape the place they're trying to represent, and that's when things get weird.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。世界上唯一真正精确的地图，大概只有一张和世界一样大的地图。因此，如果你想制作一张有用的、可以拿在手里的地图，就必须开始做取舍。你必须选择自己感兴趣的信息，并舍弃哪些内容。这些选择会影响看地图的人如何看待世界。但地图的影响力并未就此结束。地图甚至能塑造它们试图代表的地方，而事情往往就是从这里开始变得诡异的。
I love a good map, and today we have three short stories about how maps have changed the real world in big and small ways. Okay, so Kurt Colestead is in the studio with me and he also loves maps. And you've written a ton of articles about maps and map projections and even you didn't article about the design of pins on maps. Oh yes, so the love is deep. It's real.
我非常喜欢好地图，今天我们准备了三个小故事，讲讲地图是如何在宏观和微观层面上改变现实世界的。库尔特·科尔斯特德就在录音室里陪着我，他也非常喜欢地图。你写过大量关于地图和地图投影的文章，甚至还写过一篇关于地图上图钉设计的文章。哦是的，所以这份热爱是深沉的。它是真实存在的。
So we're gonna talk about actually one of your favorite geographical honidies and that's exclaves and enclaves. And these are bits of land cut off from their home countries in various cool ways. Yeah, and they take a lot of forms and it gets complicated pretty fast. So I just wanted to start with something simple that listeners out there might recognize. When you look at a map of the United States, there's this little bump up in the middle and it's called the Northwest Angle
所以我们要谈论的其实是你最喜欢的地理奇观之一，也就是飞地和内飞地。这些是通过各种奇妙方式与祖国本土隔离的土地。是的，它们有很多形式，而且情况很快就会变得复杂起来。所以我只想从听众可能认出的一个简单例子开始。当你看到美国地图时，中间有一个小小的凸起，它被称为西北角。
and it sticks up from Minnesota into Canada. And right, okay, I know that one. It's basically how, like, non-Munisotans know where Minnesota is, like, and it tells it from the other, the other States up there is gonna break up. This, like, clean, straight Canadian border running along the western U.S.
它从明尼苏达州一直延伸到加拿大境内。没错，好吧，我知道那个地方。基本上，非明尼苏达州人就是通过这个来辨别明尼苏达州在哪里的，它标志着它与北部其他州的界限，打破了美国西部那条干净、笔直的加拿大边界。
and then when it hits the great legs you get this bump. Exactly. So like on the left it's all kind of a straight line and on the right it starts getting zigzaggy. And it has a really kind of neat origin story but I'm not going to go there today. Suffice it to say, cartographical errors were made. And for me growing up in Minnesota I actually always tended to picture this notch as a piece of land, like a solid, because you know, it's like part of the shape of the map. Right, right.
然后当它到达五大湖时，你就会看到这个凸起。没错。所以左边基本上是一条直线，而右边开始变得像之字形一样曲折。它有一个非常奇妙的起源故事，但我今天就不展开讲了。总之，制图学上出了一些差错。对我来说，在明尼苏达州长大的我，过去其实总是倾向于把这个缺口想象成一块坚实的土地，因为你知道，它就像地图形状的一部分。没错，没错。
But it's actually not, or at least not entirely. So the southern portion of the angle is water. And above that, there is a patch of land, and that's what's known as a practical exclave. A practical exclave. So, and the basics of exclaves and enclaves. These are areas of land that are isolated or separated in some way from the rest of the country.
但实际上并非如此，或者至少不完全是。所以西北角的南部是一片水域。在这片水域之上，有一小块陆地，这就是所谓的“实际飞地”。实际飞地。那么，关于飞地和内飞地的基础知识。这些是与国家其余部分在某种程度上被孤立或隔离开来的土地。
But what does a practical exclave mean, like in this case? Basically, the land in the angle is surrounded by Canadian land on most sides. But below, it has this area of American territorial water, which is basically a really big lake. So practically speaking, someone who wants to go directly there without leaving the US, they could do it by boat.
但是“实际飞地”在这个例子中意味着什么呢？基本上，西北角的这片土地四周大部分被加拿大领土包围。但在南部，它拥有这片美国领海，其实也就是一个非常大的湖。所以从实际操作来看，如果有人想在不离开美国的情况下直接去那里，他们可以坐船前往。
But on land, they'd actually have to drive through Canada to get back into this slice of America, which isn't impossible, it's just impractical. Right, okay, that makes sense. This actually reminds me of Point Roberts, which we actually sent Shreef to do a little story a while ago where he was, you know, went to the post office that people go to and on Point Roberts. That's pretty cool.
但在陆地上，他们实际上必须开车穿过加拿大才能回到这片美国的土地，这并非不可能，只是很不切实际。好吧，这说得通。这其实让我想起了罗伯茨角，不久前我们曾派什里夫去那里做一个小故事，你知道的，他去了人们在罗伯茨角会去的邮局。那挺酷的。
Yeah. And it's totally in that same category of X-Clave as Point Roberts. Though in the details, they're really different. The angle is huge. It's much bigger. It's relatively remote. And it's really sparsely populated by comparison. So it only has around 100 permanent residents or so, and the crossing stations are correspondingly
是的。它完全属于和罗伯茨角同一类型的飞地。尽管在细节上，它们有着很大的不同。西北角非常巨大。它大得多。它相对偏远。相比之下，那里的人口非常稀少。所以它只有大约100名常住居民左右，相应的边境检查站也
pretty minimalist. So what does it take to cross the border at the Northwest angle? For a long time, you had these little shack-like buildings called outlying area reporting stations or ors and you had to do like a video call with a border agent. Yeah, you're right. You're basically skype into the border patrol. They kind of, you know, like you once over, you show them your passport and you're on your way. I mean, it just wouldn't be practical to, you know, staff these things, right?
相当简陋。那么在西北角过境需要什么手续呢？很长一段时间里，你都会看到这些被称为“边远地区报告站”的小木屋式建筑，你必须通过视频通话与边境官员联系。是的，你说得对。你基本上是通过Skype连线边境巡逻队。他们会对你进行一番打量，你向他们出示护照，然后就可以继续前行了。我的意思是，给这些地方配备常驻工作人员实在是不切实际，对吧？
Yeah. And then I've been reading about this because I haven't been up there in a while and apparently over the last few years They've been working on streamlining things with the mobile app called Rome spelled R-O-A-M So like a way that you can kind of check in without really going through all these hoops Yeah, that's so cool. So yeah point Roberts. You have Northwest Angle You know these are fairly regional examples, like people that live there interact with them, but most people don't interact.
是的。我最近一直在读这方面的报道，因为我有一段时间没去过那里了，显然在过去的几年里，他们一直在通过一个名为“ROAM”（拼写为 R-O-A-M）的移动应用程序来简化流程，这样你就可以不用经历那么多繁琐的手续就能办理登记。是的，太酷了！所以，罗伯茨角、西北角，你知道，这些都是相当具地方特色的例子，住在那里的人会与它们产生交集，但大多数人并不会接触到。
And they're ones that have like bigger impacts on the world in general. Yeah, I mean, there's ones that people never really think about. And a really good example is the whole state of Alaska. Right, okay, of course. So Alaska is considered to be what's called a semi-X-clave. And it's actually the largest of its kind in the world.
而有些对世界有着更广泛的影响。是的，我是说，有些地方人们从不真正去想它们。一个很好的例子就是整个阿拉斯加州。好吧，当然。所以阿拉斯加被认为是一个“半飞地”。它实际上是同类中世界上面积最大的。
And it's got this semi-modifier, because even though it doesn't border the lower 48, it does have this really long stretch of international coastline, so it really has direct access to international waters. Right. Right. Okay, so those are exclaves. I think those are pretty easy to understand. So describe what onclaves are are because those can be pretty strange.
它之所以带有“半”这个修饰词，是因为尽管它与美国本土48州不接壤，但它拥有很长一段国际海岸线，因此它确实可以直接通往国际水域。没错。好吧，这些就是飞地。我觉得这些挺容易理解的。那么请描述一下什么是内飞地，因为那些可能会非常奇怪。
They really can. And I should note here that there are some nuances to all this and a lot of complexity. Like some enclaves are also exclaves. But like in the simplest and most general terms, enclaves are countries or parts of countries that are entirely contained within another country's territory. So they're totally surrounded. So North West Angle and Point Roberts and Alaska, they don't count because they aren't cut off completely from the US. So you can still get to these places by boat, for example.
确实很奇怪。我在这里应该指出，所有这些都有一些细微差别和很大的复杂性。比如有些内飞地同时也是飞地。但用最简单、最通俗的话来说，内飞地是完全包含在另一个国家领土内的国家或部分国家。所以它们被完全包围了。因此，西北角、罗伯茨角和阿拉斯加都不算数，因为它们并没有完全与美国本土切断联系。比方说，你仍然可以乘船到达这些地方。
Yeah, exactly. Whereas enclaves are fully enclosed. So San Marino in Europe is a classic example. It's this relatively small country and it's completely unclaved on all sides by Italy. I mean maybe it's because the US is so isolated and on its own and surrounded by water that that feels weird to me to be enclosed in another country. I mean maybe if you're like the Czech Republic you're surrounded by other countries. Yeah, we're like Luxembourg or something. It's like, you know, it might have
是的，完全正确。而内飞地则是被完全封闭的。所以欧洲的圣马力诺就是一个经典的例子。这是一个相对较小的国家，四周完全被意大利包围。我的意思是，也许是因为美国太孤立、太独立而且四周环水，被另一个国家包围对我来说感觉很诡异。我的意思是，也许如果你像捷克共和国那样，你会被其他国家包围。是的，或者像卢森堡什么的。就像，你知道的，它可能是
be one country, but it's still pretty small. But there's still something kind of special about being a country completely inside one other country. Yeah. Yeah. You're kind of dependent on them in certain curious ways. Exactly. And that's sort of just the first level of this, too. These things get even more complex and even more small, in a lot of cases, for example, with counter enclaves, which are an enclave inside of another enclave, or more specifically a piece of the Netherlands inside a piece of Belgium that is itself in the Netherlands.
一个国家，但它仍然相当小。不过，作为一个完全位于另一个国家内部的国家，仍然有着某种特殊之处。是的。你确实在某些奇妙的方面依赖着它们。没错。而这其实也只是第一层。在许多情况下，这些情况会变得更加复杂、更加微小，例如“次级内飞地”（或译反飞地），即内飞地内部的内飞地，或者更具体地说，是一块属于荷兰的土地夹在了一块属于比利时的土地中间，而这块比利时的土地本身又位于荷兰境内。
So the second order enclaves are like enclaves and enclaves. Yes. enclaves all the way down. All the way down. And as crazy as those are, it doesn't stop there. Consider counter enclaves like a piece of India inside a piece of Bangladesh inside a piece of India inside a Bangladesh. And in fact, that triple enclave example is the only known
所以二级内飞地就像是内飞地套内飞地。是的。内飞地套内飞地，层层嵌套。层层嵌套。不管听起来多疯狂，还没完呢。想想反飞地，比如一块印度领土夹在孟加拉国领土中间，而这块孟加拉国领土又夹在印度领土中间，然后外面又是孟加拉国。事实上，这种三重内飞地是世界历史上已知的唯一一个
third-order enclave in world history. Yeah. Well, that makes sense that it would be the only one. Yeah, I mean, it's in so absurd. It's pretty, yeah. I mean, it's pretty hard to picture. So how does that even work in the real world? So basically, for a long time, there were villages within villages and at the middle of it all was this two acre parcel that was owned by a Bangladesh farmer who lived in the surrounding enclave and he would just wake up in the morning, cross into India to farm his tiny patch of land in the middle of this zone and then he would cross back into Bangladesh each night. In 2015, India and Bangladesh finally agreed to this really big cross-border landswap, to essentially tidy up all these enclave within enclaves. And essentially, they ended up handing over dozens of enclaves to each other, totaling thousands of acres.
三级内飞地。好吧，那它成为唯一的一个也就说得通了。是的，我是说，这太荒谬了。确实，是的。我是说，这很难想象。那这在现实世界里到底是怎么运作的呢？基本上，很长一段时间里，那里都有村中之村，而这一切的中心是一块两英亩的土地，由一位孟加拉国农民拥有，他住在周围的内飞地里，他每天早晨醒来，穿境进入印度，去耕种这个地带中间他那一小块土地，然后每天晚上再穿境回到孟加拉国。2015年，印度和孟加拉国终于同意进行这次规模宏大的跨国土地置换，基本上是为了理顺所有这些内飞地套内飞地的混乱状况。最终，他们向对方移交了数十块内飞地，总面积达数千英亩。
Did that mean that there were like Indians now living in Bangladesh and vice versa? I mean, yes, in some cases, and I actually thought they handled it pretty well and pragmatically. They basically offered residents of these former enclave as a choice. They could either stay where they were and basically be in a different country than they had been before, or they could move, quote, unquote, back across the border to their official country of citizenship. And it all kind of reminds me like this isn't quite technically an enclave or an exclave thing. But once you start thinking in these terms, there are some other interesting geographical mindbinders out there. So I've got one more for you.
那是不是意味着现在有印度人住在孟加拉国，反之亦然？我是说，是的，在某些情况下确实如此，而且我觉得他们处理得相当不错且务实。他们基本上给了这些前内飞地居民一个选择：他们可以留在原地，也就是生活在一个与之前不同的国家里；或者他们可以“搬回”国境线另一边，回到他们正式拥有公民身份的国家。这一切让我想起——这在技术上不完全是一个内飞地或飞地的概念。但一旦你开始用这种思维方式思考，外面还有一些其他有趣的地理脑筋急转弯。所以我还要为你出个谜题。
And as far as I know, this place has no official name. So I've just been calling it Inception Island. And it's a pretty normal island located in Canada. But apparently as far as I can tell, it's also the world's largest known island in a lake on an island in a lake on an island. It's like inception. Like there's a dream within a dream within a dream within a dream within a dream. Exactly. So that's why you're exactly. So that's why you're calling this one. Yeah, I get it. And it kind of blows my mind in the same way too, right? Like, I have to do some like mental, you know, accounting to keep track of the what's within
据我所知，这个地方没有官方名称。所以我一直叫它“盗梦空间岛”（Inception Island）。它是加拿大境内一个非常普通的岛屿。但显然据我所知，它也是世界上已知的最大的一座岛中湖中岛中湖中岛。就像《盗梦空间》一样。就像梦中梦中梦中梦中梦。没错。所以这就是你称呼这个名字的原因。没错。所以这就是你称呼这个的名字的原因。是的，我懂了。这同样让我感到脑洞大开，对吧？就像，我必须在脑子里做一些盘算，才能搞清楚到底是什么包含在什么
what? That's right. As you go a lot. Now in a dream, our mind continuously does this. We create and perceive our world simultaneously. And our mind does this so well that we don't even know what's happening. Does the top keep spinning? Who knows?
里面？没错。随着你不断深入。现在在梦中，我们的大脑一直在这样做。我们同时创造和感知我们的世界。而且我们的大脑做得如此之好，以至于我们甚至不知道发生了什么。图腾还在旋转吗？谁知道呢？
Who knows? Who knows? And so of course we have pictures of these all on the website. Oh yeah. Of course. Cool. That's awesome. That's at 9-9-PI.org.
谁知道呢？谁知道呢？所以当然，我们在网站上放了这些照片。哦，是的。当然。酷。太棒了。就在 9-9-PI.org。
Thank you, Kurt. Yeah, I am Timerman. I'm next is Joe Rosenberg. Okay, so Roman, the best way to get into this story I think is with kind of like a mental exercise, are you game? I'm definitely game. Alright, so what I want you to do is imagine that you are taking a stroll through the British countryside. Okay. Does it matter where in the British countryside?
谢谢你，库尔特。是的，我是蒂默曼。接下来是乔·罗森伯格。好吧，罗曼，我觉得进入这个故事的最佳方式是通过一种思维练习，你敢接受挑战吗？我绝对敢。好的，那么我要你做的是，想象你正在英国的乡村漫步。好的。英国乡村的哪个地方有关系吗？
Actually, no, it actually doesn't matter. That's kind of the point. It could be anywhere on the island of Great Britain. Okay. So let's ramble through the Lake District. I like a good fell. I could ramble on a fell. Excellent choice. Excellent word of use.
其实没有，真的没关系。这正是重点所在。它可以是大不列颠岛上的任何地方。好的。那我们在湖区漫步吧。我喜欢连绵的小山。我可以在山丘上漫步。绝佳的选择。用词非常恰当。
Okay. The hedges around there. Definitely, definitely throwing a good hedge, throwing some sheep. Okay, I'm there in my mind. I'm rambling. It's a beautiful place. I'm glad you're enjoying yourself.
好的。那里的树篱。绝对的，绝对要穿过一个漂亮的树篱，赶几只羊。好的，我在脑海里了。我在漫步。这是一个美丽的地方。很高兴你玩得开心。
But here's the thing, on this hypothetical ramble of yours, no matter where you chose to go. So long as you are somewhere on the island of Great Britain, after a while, I can almost guarantee you, you will come across an object that looks like this. Here, let me show you a photo. It's like an obelisk. It looks a little bit like a fatter, squatter, washing in monument without a pyramid on top, which is like kind of a tapered concrete pillar. I can't tell from the perspective how quality it is though. It's maybe like four feet high. Okay. Yeah. So in the middle of the countryside,
但关键是，在你这次假设的漫步中，无论你选择去哪里，只要你身处大不列颠岛上，过一会儿，我几乎可以向你保证，你会遇到一个长成这样的物体。来，我给你看张照片。它就像一个方尖碑。它看起来有点像华盛顿纪念碑更胖、更矮的变体，顶部没有金字塔，它是一个略呈锥形的混凝土柱。不过从这个角度我看不出它的材质如何。它大概有四英尺高吧。好的。是的。在乡村的中央，
it's very austere. It looks like a ruin kind of. It has a little vibe of something that has been left behind, but it's cool looking. It's a vocative. Yeah, yeah. I mean, for me, it's almost like a gray concrete version of the monolith from 2001. It's just kind of there. And the thing is, is that these pillars are actually all over the place.
它非常简朴。它看起来有点像废墟。它有一种被遗留在原地的氛围，但看起来很酷。很引人遐思。是的，是的。对我说，它几乎就像《2001太空漫游》中那块黑色巨石的灰色混凝土版本。它就那样静静地立在那里。关键是，这样的柱子实际上到处都是。
No matter where you are, if you head out a few miles in any direction, you will keep stumbling upon these things. And they all basically look like this? Yeah, they're all identical, exact same shape, exact same measurements. It almost never varies. This one you're looking at is in Wales. Let me show you a few more.
无论你在哪里，如果你朝任何方向走上几英里，你就会不断地偶遇这些东西。它们基本上都长这样吗？是的，它们完全相同，形状一模一样，尺寸完全一样。几乎没有什么变化。你看到的这个在威尔士。我再给你看几个。
This is one that's actually in an island called St. Kilda that's like in the outer hebrides, like super remote. There's like a band-in settlement there. There's like in the outer Hebrides, like super remote. There's like abandoned settlements there There's all there is as a military base out there But still they have these pillars. They're really are everywhere And like for example not just in these like remote craggy places This one's just in a field in a farm field. Yeah, we got one here that's just like in a kind of suburban backyard So what are they and why are they everywhere?
这是另一个实际上位于圣基尔达岛上的柱子，那个岛在赫布里底群岛外围，超级偏远。那里有一个废弃的定居点。那里只有一个军事基地。但它们依然有这些柱子。它们真的无处不在。比如不仅仅在这些偏远、崎岖的地方。这一个只是在农田里的一片土地上。是的，我们这里有一个甚至就在某种郊区后院里。那么它们是什么？为什么到处都是？
So the actual technical term for these things are triangulation stations. But in Britain everyone just calls them trig points or trig pillars. And these trig pillars are the remnants of a centuries-long effort to do something that we today kind of take for granted, which was to make a topographical survey of an entire country. Huh. And so a topographical survey of the entire country, I kind of know what you mean, but what do you mean?
所以这些东西的实际专业术语是“三角测量站”。但在英国，每个人都只管它们叫“三角点”或者“三角柱”。这些三角柱是几个世纪努力的遗迹，为的是做一件我们今天觉得理所当然的事——对整个国家进行地形测绘。哦。所以对整个国家进行地形测绘，我大致明白你的意思，但你具体指什么？
Right, yeah, yeah, you're like, yeah, sure, the survey is the right thing. They're not doing the thing. They have those things. And then there's topo maps and it's all taken care of. The kind of broader contextual answer is at least in Europe, as you get into the age of exploration and colonization, but also the age of nation states with standing armies, there is an increased need for really spatially accurate maps. And this is because navigation and military actions and that sort of thing, like you need
对，是的，是的，你可能会想，“没错，测绘就是那么回事嘛。他们又不是在凭空捏造。他们有那些工具。”然后还有地形图，一切都搞定了。更广泛的背景答案是，至少在欧洲，随着你进入大航海和殖民时代，同时也进入了拥有常备军的民族国家时代，对空间精确地图的需求不断增加。这是因为航海和军事行动以及诸如此类的事情，你需要
to be more precise than you did before, is that the deal? Yeah, exactly. I mean, if you're going to aim an artillery piece, you really need to know. You know what you're going to hit. What you're going to hit, for sure, the earth, things like this, right? Okay. But the first top graphically accurate survey maps were only of certain small areas, like maybe a coastline or a town. And it turned out that most of these maps weren't even that accurate. Because anytime they tried to line them up side by side,
比以前更精确，是这样吗？是的，完全正确。我的意思是，如果你要瞄准火炮，你真的需要知道。你知道你要击中什么。你要击中的目标，当然，还有地球，诸如此类的事情，对吧？好吧。但第一批地形精确的测绘地图只针对某些小区域，比如海岸线或某个城镇。结果证明，这些地图大都不怎么精确。因为任何时候只要他们尝试把这些地图并排对齐，
they were never in agreement. Like their longitude and latitude would never sync up. And it was hard to say which map was right, or whether perhaps even all the maps were just filled with errors. There were no national maps, no national grid systems, which is to say there's no set of fixed reference points for all lower order maps to use. And this was really frustrating.
它们永远无法吻合。比如它们的经纬度永远无法同步。很难说哪张地图是对的，或者也许所有的地图都充满了错误。当时没有国家地图，没有国家网格系统，也就是说，没有供所有低精度地图使用的一套固定参考点。这真的很让人沮丧。
Just like imagine for a moment, not having a consistent map of the country where you lived. Right, like every time you saw a big map in a classroom, the coast would be all different and Florida would look crazy every time. And that sort of thing, like everything would be different. Yeah, because nobody really knew.
试想一下，如果你连一张你所居住国家的连贯地图都没有。没错，就像每次你在教室里看到巨幅地图时，海岸线都会大变样，佛罗里达州每次看起来都怪里怪气的。诸如此类的事情，一切都会变来变去。是的，因为当时没有人真正知道。
Right, right. And I don't know about you, but if that were ever taken away, I would feel its absence. And so in Europe, increasingly, as you get into the 18th century, especially, there is a desire for precisely that, a true God's eye view of the land that would feel like you're just kind of floating many miles above the earth and looking down at what is actually. And this was kind of a new idea to be really accurate in this way. Yeah, because in Europe and the Middle Ages, you didn't need to know exactly how far away bruise was.
对的，对的。我不知道你怎么样，但如果这些地图被拿走，我会感受到它们的缺失。因此在欧洲，越来越多的人，特别是在进入18世纪时，开始渴望精准的东西——一种真正的上帝视角，让你感觉自己仿佛漂浮在地球上方数英里处，俯瞰着真实的一切。这种追求极致精确的想法在当时算是一种新思路。是的，因为在欧洲的中世纪，你不需要确切知道布鲁日离你有多远。
It was like three days right away to the left, right? And your field, it wasn't that it was 255 yards long versus 257 yards long. It just ended where the cops of trees was, right? Still the way we use subway maps today, right? Which is something that helps you in practice. But now we're getting into this era where there is a kind of practical need. But also you have this enlightenment idea
感觉就像向左走三天的路程，对吧？还有你的田地，它不是255码长还是257码长的区别。它就在那丛灌木林结束的地方，对吧？这仍然类似于我们今天使用地铁图的方式，对吧？这是一种在实践中对你有帮助的东西。但现在我们进入了一个新时代，这里存在着一种实际需求。同时你也拥有了这种启蒙运动的思想，
that there is some kind of fixed objective reality out there that we have been denied access to up until now. And we need to find out everything we can about it and master it somehow as part of our grand enlightenment project. And so in the 1700s, you begin to see more and more countries start to do national surveys and make the first spatially accurate national maps who kind of official coordinates keep all the other maps in agreement. And so by fits and starts in the 1780s and then officially in 1791, Britain is finally like,
即外面存在着某种固定的、客观的现实，而我们直到现在才得以接触。我们需要发现关于它的一切，并作为我们宏伟的启蒙项目的一部分，以某种方式去掌握它。所以在18世纪，你会看到越来越多的国家开始进行国家测绘，制作第一批空间精确的国家地图，用官方坐标让所有其他地图保持一致。因此，经过18世纪80年代的零星尝试，并于1791年正式启动，英国终于觉得，
hmm, we should also probably know where everything is. And they said, you know what, we want a national map too, let's do it. Great, okay, so how do you go about making a national map? Where do you even start, right? When you don't know where anything is, and you're not sure about anything's location or the distance between things,
嗯，我们大概也应该知道所有东西都在什么位置。他们说，你知道吗，我们也想要一张国家地图，让我们干吧。太好了，好吧，那么你该如何着手制作一张国家地图呢？你甚至从哪里开始呢，对吧？当你对任何东西的位置都一无所知，并且不确定任何事物的位置或事物之间的距离时，
what's your first reference point, like how do you decide where? There it is. And the answer is trick pillars. And this is what they did. They built two triangulation stations, about 12 miles apart. Kind of what Heathrow Airport is now.
你的第一个参考点是什么？你是怎么决定地点的？就是它。答案就是三角柱。这就是他们的做法。他们建造了两个三角测量站，相距大约12英里。大约就是现在希思罗机场所在的位置。
And then they used, just so they think they got the measurement exactly right, they used a series of glass tubes. I think each glass tube was like 12 feet long and they just kept placing them end on end over the course of like many, many months until they finally could add them all up and say, okay, this is the distance between these two first triangulation stations. Those two triangulation stations were within sight of the Greenwich Observatory. And the Greenwich Observatory, they were like pretty sure they knew where the Greenwich
然后为了确保测量绝对准确，他们使用了一系列玻璃管。我想每根玻璃管大约12英尺长，他们就这样一根接一根地排下去，历时好几个月，直到最后把它们加起来说：“好吧，这就是最初这两个三角测量站之间的距离。”这两个三角测量站都在格林威治天文台的视线范围内。至于格林威治天文台，他们相当确定格林威治
Observatory was because it had all these telescopes with which to make celestial measurements. And so like the Greenwich Observatories, the Longitude and Latitude was the Longitude and Latitude they were like the most confident in. All we need to do now is measure the angle between these two stations and the Greenwich Observatory. And now we have the location and distance between all three of these objects. And once they had that, then they were off to the races. Because now you don't need to physically measure layout, like rulers or glass rods or anything anymore. All you need to do is place a new triangulation,
天文台的位置，因为它拥有所有这些用来进行天文测量的望远镜。所以像格林威治天文台的经纬度，是他们最有信心的经纬度。我们现在需要做的，就是测量这两座观测站与格林威治天文台之间的夹角。现在我们就知道了所有这三个物体之间的位置和距离。一旦他们掌握了这些，他们就可以大显身手了。因为现在你不再需要用尺子或玻璃棒等工具进行实地测量了。你只需要放置一个新的三角测量站——
a third triangulation station within sight of the first two, measure the angles again, and then you can just do all the math from the angles and you get to know the exact location of the third triangulation station. Okay. And then you can put a fourth a little further away. Right.
一个在头两个测量站视线范围内的第三个三角测量站，再次测量角度，然后你就可以通过这些角度进行所有的数学计算，从而得出第三个三角测量站的确切位置。好的。然后你可以再放一个稍微远一点的。没错。
And again, it's along with the site of two, get a fourth station, a fifth, right? And then you just daisy chain your way across the entire landmax. Well, in this case, you mean Great Britain. And that's why there's trig points everywhere. For the entire island of Great Britain, yes, with triangulation stations at every point. Wow. How long does this take? The primary triangulation was finally completed in 1853, so it took 62 years.
同样，它位于其他两个点的视线范围内，以此类推得到第四个、第五个测站，对吧？然后你只需像串雏菊一样，在整个陆地上串联过去。好吧，在这种情况下，你指的是大不列颠。这就是为什么到处都是三角点的原因。对于整个大不列颠岛来说，是的，每个点都有三角测量站。哇。这花了多长时间？初级三角测量最终于1853年完成，所以历时62年。
And in fact, like, in 1935, they did a re-triangulation. And this time, it was much faster. It only took 30 years. And so all the trig pillars you see dotted throughout the countryside, I have to fess up, are actually from the retryangulation. These are the second ones from 1935. Yeah, and then the reason they installed these new ones is like the original ones were just like holes in the ground. And there's actually hilarious descriptions of where you could find them, like because they'd be like, oh, ask the farmer, lives at the end of
事实上，在1935年，他们进行了一次重新三角测量。这一次，速度快得多。只花了30年。所以我得承认，你在乡村各处看到的那些星罗棋布的三角柱，其实都来自重新三角测量。这些是1935年的第二批三角柱。是的，他们安装这些新柱子的原因是因为最初的那些基本上只是地上的洞。而且关于去哪里找它们，还有一些滑稽的描述，比如他们会说，哦，去问问住在小路尽头的那个农民，他会告诉你，你知道我的意思吗？这些竟然就是三角点位置的官方描述。
the lane and he'll tell you, do you know what I mean? And those were like, in the official descriptions of where the trig points were. And they're like, this isn't good enough. We need to make better trig points, more trig points. And the reason they are all the exact same shape is because they are literally mounts for the surveying equipment.
他们觉得这还不够好。我们需要更好的三角点，更多的三角点。它们形状完全相同的原因是，它们字面意思上就是测绘仪器的基座。
Oh, okay, that makes sense. So in the end, for the full survey, how many trig points do they have to build? They built about 6500. Okay. And today, there are still about 6200. Oh, wow. Yeah, it's pretty good. And believe you're not, there is one guy who has visited every single one of them. Of course. It happened a bit by bit really. So this is the guy. His name is Rob Woodall. He is 59.
哦，原来如此，这说得通。所以最后，为了完成整个测绘，他们一共建造了多少个三角点？他们建造了大约6500个。好的。而今天，大约还剩下6200个。哦，哇。是的，相当不错。信不信由你，有一个人去过其中每一个三角点。当然。其实是一点一点完成的。这就是这个人。他叫罗伯·伍德尔（Rob Woodall）。他59岁。
He works for a Water and Waste Authority in East Anglia. And he honestly cannot tell you what compelled him to do this. You left set out to buy six thousand trig pillars. Yeah, just gradually you get kind of sucked in. I mean, Rob likes the outdoors and he likes a good challenge, clearly. But when I asked him if there was some kind of philosophical reward in it for him, something to do with perhaps seeing all of Britain, he was like, no. But yeah, in terms of discovering stuff, I didn't find it.
他在东安格利亚的一家水务和废物管理局工作。老实说，他自己也说不清是什么促使他这么做的。你一开始并不是为了买下六千个三角柱而出发的。是的，就是渐渐地被卷进去了。我的意思是，罗伯喜欢户外活动，而且显然喜欢挑战。但当我问他从中是否得到了某种哲学上的回报，比如看到了整个英国时，他说并没有。不过，是的，就发现新事物而言，我并没有发现。
I'm not a kind of guy really. I'm not I'm not in that much poetry in my soul. I'm afraid. Rob has no poetry in his soul for guy. I think it's yeah, he's beat a little self aggregating. I think for sure. I clearly if he did this, he does. He can't articulate it that sense. That's what a... what are what are for more people and i really like them right and and that sense like he is not alone he is part of a small but flourishing community of people called trick backers uh... elective visit and cataloged trick points but so far
我其实不是那种人。我灵魂深处没有那么多诗意。恐怕是这样的。罗伯的灵魂里没有诗意。我觉得这...是的，他有点自我贬低。我觉得肯定的。很明显，如果他做了这件事，他是有的。他只是无法用言语表达那种感受。这就是...对更多人来说，我是真的很喜欢它们，对吧？从某种意义上说，他并不孤单，他是被称为“寻星客”（注：指收集并打卡英国三角点的户外爱好者）的一小群蓬勃发展的人的一部分，他们热衷于拜访和编目三角点。但到目前为止，
rob is the only one to visit every single one uh... he says one guy was neck and neck with him for a while but retired at five thousand came for somebody else that don't fall for000, and then, fortunately, I think he had a row that accident, so he gave up a bit after 4,000. There's a lady called Carol Engle that has done, I think, something like 5,300. I mean, she's about 10 years behind me, but she's very, very keen. You know, I think for most of the trig baggers, the core poetic motivation is the same poetic
罗伯是唯一一个去过每一个三角点的人。他说曾有一个家伙有一段时间和他旗鼓相当，但在4000个的时候退休了，换了另一个人...对，然后不幸的是，我想他出了一场划船事故，所以在4000个之后不久就放弃了。有一位叫卡罗尔·恩格尔（Carol Engle）的女士，我想她已经完成了大约5300个。我的意思是，她比我落后大约10年，但她非常非常热心。你知道，我想对于大多数寻星客来说，核心的诗意动机和任何决定出来的人的诗意动机是一样的——
motivation as anyone who decides they want to come out. Just because it's there. Precisely. Because it's there. Although, you know, in this case, you might say like there is a lot of there there. Rob says it took him close to 12 years to visit them all. I got there and kind of 5,000 of relatively quickly really but the last thousand of them were really hard. It's what makes the last thousand so hard. Well part of it is that some of them are just in really remote places.
因为山就在那里。正是如此。因为山就在那里。虽然，你知道，在这种情况下，你可能会说这里“干货”确实很多。罗伯说他花了将近12年的时间才把它们全部走完。我其实挺快就走完了大约5000个，但最后的那一千个真的很难。是什么让最后的一千个变得那么难？嗯，部分原因是一些三角点真的在非常偏远的地方。
That's what makes sense. You know there are some of them are just like on these sea cliff islands with no real place to land. So it's almost like a mini expedition just to get to them. A lot of them are also just like in these overgrown areas or places left to the elements in one way or another. And Rob says like a lot of trig pillars of starts kind of crumble away. Like there was one that was on the edge of a sea cliff apparently that a few years back was about to tumble into the sea.
这就说得通了。你知道，有些地方简直就像是在海崖孤岛上，根本没有真正可以登陆的地方。所以去这些地方几乎就像是一次小型探险。还有很多地方只是处于杂草丛生的区域，或者以这样或那样的方式任由大自然侵蚀。罗伯说，很多三角柱开始时都会慢慢风化碎裂。显然，有一次有一个柱子在海崖边缘，几年差点掉进海里。
And yeah, so somebody noticed it fallen over and then the next people went, he's been finding down the bottom of the cliff and the farmer had actually managed to rescue it and pull it back. We just get back from the cliff and the farmer actually managed to rescue it and pull it back. You know, when you get back from the cliff and re-arrêt to it, a little way back and that was really nice. But if the farmer put it back up, did he put it on the exact same point?
是的，所以有人发现它倒了，然后下一拨人去的时候，发现它已经掉到悬崖底下了，而那个农民居然设法把它救了回来，又把它拉了上来。我们刚从悬崖回来，那个农民居然设法把它救了回来，把它拉了上来。你知道，当你从悬崖回来并重新安置它时，把它往回挪了一点，这真的很棒。但如果农民把它放回去，他把它放在完全相同的准确位置了吗？
I mean, does it still serve? As a trig point, if you move it to another place. No, he had to move, obviously, like, the point where it was was now just in mid-air. Right, right. And so we had to move it, and so where it was was now just in midair right right and so we had to move And so no longer is a functioning Trig point and there is a further irony which is that all of this wear and tear can also make certain trig points somewhat paradoxically hard to find Sometimes they just disappear completely and sometimes they reappear somewhere completely unexpected
我的意思是，如果你把它搬到另一个地方，它还能作为三角点吗？不，他不得不移动它，很显然，它原来的那个点现在已经悬空了。对，对。所以我们不得不移动它，所以它原来的位置现在悬空了，对，对。所以我们不得不移动它。因此它不再是一个具功能的三角点，这里还有一个更进一步的讽刺之处，那就是所有这些磨损也可能使某些三角点在某种程度上自相矛盾地变得很难找到。有时它们会完全消失，有时又会在完全意想不到的地方重新出现。
There's one that he turned up in Scotland, not seeing yet. Yeah, they do come back sometimes. I don't even know what that means. It just means that they will disappear from their known location and then reappear in a new location and exactly what hands they passed through in between is no one knows.
有一个三角点竟然在苏格兰出现了，他还没见过呢。是的，它们有时真的会回来。我甚至不知道这意味着什么。这只意味着它们会从已知的位置消失，然后在一个新的位置重新出现，至于在此期间它们经手了谁，谁也不知道。
Rob actually says that at one point, another trig pillar showed up on eBay, and one of the UK trig backers had to intervene to make sure it wasn't sold overseas. Although most trig points, if they are interfered with, are interacted with in kind of more innocent ways. So as more and more people have learned about them in recent years, more and more getting painted, let me show you with you. This is an English rose. Yeah. It's kind of been stenciled on a red English rose. This is a well-strag and well-strag and very good. So obviously in Wales. But my favorite has to be the minions.
罗伯甚至说，有一次另一个三角柱出现在了eBay上，英国的一位寻星客不得不出手干预，以确保它不会被卖到海外。尽管大多数三角点如果受到干扰，也是以比较无害的方式进行的。近年来，随着越来越多的人了解它们，越来越多的三角点被涂上了颜色，我给你看一个。这是一朵英格兰玫瑰。是的。它被丝网印刷在一朵红色的英格兰玫瑰上。这是一个保存完好且非常不错的三角点。这显然是在威尔士。但我的最爱绝对是“小黄人”（Minions）。
It's a straight-up minion. It's a straight-up minion. But the proportions are very good. Very good. You like someone to realize this these things are minions. It's a straight-up menu. But the proportions are very good. Very good. You like someone to realize these things are miniatures. They nailed it. They nailed it. So I really is. I find it really quite charming. But the thing that Rob told me that really got me thinking is that the trick pillars are
它就是一个纯粹的小黄人。它真的是一个小黄人。但比例非常好。非常棒。你喜欢有人意识到这些东西是微缩模型。它真的是一个小黄人。但比例非常好。非常棒。你喜欢有人意识到这些东西是微缩模型。他们做得很完美。他们做得很完美。所以我真的很喜欢。我觉得这非常迷人。但罗伯告诉我的一件事真正引发了我的思考，那就是三角柱
only the tip of a much larger surveying infrastructure that is actually all around us. Because those just provide the starting points for any given map. For all the lower order measurements like the streets and hills and the rivers and the slopes. Surveys used much much smaller markings, really just these little notches made in the landscape. It's sometimes a small plaque called a benchmark, but sometimes it was like a notch just called a cut mark. If you keep your eyes out, you tend to see it in the UK anyway, you tend to see them. The huge numbers of them, it's probably about a million of them put in, I would think. There's a million at least, much marks, just around the landscape. Wow. That was my reaction as well.
只是更大测绘基础设施的冰山一角，而这种基础设施实际上就在我们周围。因为这些只是为任何给定地图提供了起点。对于所有低精度的测量，比如街道、山丘、河流和斜坡，测量员使用的是更小得多的标记，实际上只是景观中制作的小切口。有时是一个叫“水准标”的小牌子，但有时它只是一个叫做“刻痕”的切口。如果你留心观察，在英国你往往能看到它们。数量极其庞大，我想大概有一百万个吧。景观周围至少有一百万个水准标。哇。这也是我的反应。
I've got one about 200 meters away from my house, actually. Just jizzled into, I think, it's number 40, and I was state. That's incredible. And so like someone like your neighbor down the street, like do you do know whether they know that that mark is on their house? I've never thought of mentioning it, actually, they probably don't might be fun to mention sometimes, but a bit of a strength into us, really.
其实离我房子大约200米的地方就有一个。就凿在，我想，是40号房子上，我住的那条街。太不可思议了。所以就像你街坊邻居那样，他们知道那个标记在他们房子上吗？我从来没想过提这件事，其实，他们可能不知道。提一下有时可能会挺好，但对我们来说确实有点怪异。
I guess the point is that these thousands of trig pillars and however many benchmarks and millions of cut marks are just kind of secretly all around us. That's so cool. Yeah, and they're not just in Britain. Like, lots of countries have some form of physical surveying infrastructure in place. So India has its own kind of triangulation stations, so does Japan and the US. And the only reason we're not as familiar with them is they're not as dramatic looking.
我想重点是，这数千个三角柱以及无论多少的水准标和数百万个切口，都只是秘密地存在于我们周围。太酷了。是的，而且不仅在英国。许多国家都有某种形式的实体测绘基础设施。所以印度有它自己的三角测量站，日本和美国也是如此。我们之所以对它们不那么熟悉，只是因为它们看起来没有那么引人注目。
They're more like, they're more like cut marks. They're just like little cairns or poles or plaques in the ground. They are everywhere, and it's strange to think that there is this kind of invisible network of objects all around us that actually is responsible for giving us a way to look at ourselves from outside ourselves. That's kind of amazing, that it gives us so much these little things. That's awesome. Well thanks Joe. Ramen thank you so much. What happens when the map says there are monsters everywhere and people flock there to catch them all after this. After this Here is Vivian Lei Roman have you ever heard of a town called acaquan?
它们更像是...更像是刻痕。它们只是地上的小石堆、柱子或牌匾。它们无处不在，一想到我们周围存在着这样一种无形的物体网络，正是它们赋予了我们一种从外部审视自身的方式，就会觉得很奇怪。这真是太棒了，这些小东西能给我们带来这么多。太棒了。谢谢你，乔。罗曼，非常感谢。当地图上说到处都是怪物，人们蜂拥而至去捕捉它们时，会发生什么？广告之后揭晓。广告之后。我是维维安·莱（Vivian Lei）。罗曼，你听说过一个叫奥科宽（Occoquan）的小镇吗？
Say it again. Have you ever heard of a town called acaquan? Acaquan Nope, never heard of a town called Ocaquon? No, I don't say that. Just for the town name. Ocaquon. No, I've never heard of it. Ocaquon is this beautiful little town in Virginia, and it's very old, and it's right on the water, and it looks like pretty much the perfect setting for a CW drama about a prestigious East Coast boarding school. Perfect. So it's quaint and vintage and kind of playing up on the history and the country style but also very upscale. So who is that? So that is Lauren Jacobs. She's an artist and a teacher based in Northern Virginia. So in 2015, Lauren won a
再说一遍。你听说过一个叫奥科宽的小镇吗？奥科宽。从来没听说过一个叫奥科宽的小镇？不，我没说过。就为了这个镇名。奥科宽。不，我从来没听说过。奥科宽是弗吉尼亚州一个美丽的小镇，非常古老，紧邻水边，它看起来几乎是一部关于东海岸一所声望卓著的寄宿学校的CW电视台电视剧的完美取景地。完美。所以它古色古香、充满复古风情，带有一种历史感和田园风格，但同时也非常高端。那那是谁？那是劳伦·雅各布斯（Lauren Jacobs）。她是一位居住在弗吉尼亚州北部的艺术家和老师。因此在2015年，劳伦赢得了一个
jury prize, meaning she'd get to exhibit and sell her work at a gallery in Ocaquon called the Artists Undertaking. The artist's undertaking gallery is called that because it used to be the Undertaker's house. Oh nice. It's like haunted. It's like God. It's like God. I love it. The town is like 300 years old, so you can find like a ton of these really cool historic sites like that around Ocaquan. I mean, it's completely full of really interesting history. Like they have this famous ghost tour and Ocaquan has all of these kind of quote, unquote certified ghost sites and ghost sightings.
评审奖，这意味着她可以在奥科宽的一家名为“艺术家承办商”（The Artists Undertaking）的画廊里展出和出售她的作品。“艺术家承办商”画廊之所以叫这个名字，是因为它过去是殡仪馆老板的房子。哦，不错。就像闹鬼一样。就像上帝。就像上帝。我太喜欢了。这个小镇有大约300年的历史，所以你可以在奥科宽周围找到大量这样非常酷的历史遗迹。我的意思是，这里到处都是非常有趣的历史。比如他们有一个著名的幽灵之旅，而且奥科宽拥有所有这些所谓的“认证幽灵地点”和“幽灵目击事件”。
What does she mean when she says a certified ghost? Like, how do you get a ghost certified in this world? There's an organization. They'll come by and then confirm the validity of your haunting. Of course. And I think I unintentionally made Occoquan sound like the town from Hocus Pocus.
当她说“认证幽灵”时，她是什么意思？在这个世界上，你该如何让一个幽灵获得认证呢？有一个组织。他们会顺道过来，然后确认你闹鬼事件的真实性。当然。我想我不小心把奥科宽说得听起来像电影《女巫也疯狂》（Hocus Pocus）里的那个小镇了。
But it's actually this really nice area to go shopping. There's lots of one of a kind mom and pop shops that tend to do cater to definitely a wealthier demographic who wanted to spend the day strolling along the river and maybe buying a $400 pair of sunglasses and then go in teaking. This was more or less the type of clientele that Lawrence gallery depended on for sales too. At the time, we were working a lot off of walk-in traffic, clients who were coming in and they were looking for a really special gift and coming in to spend several hundred dollars.
但实际上，这是一个非常适合购物的好地方。这里有很多独一无二的夫妻店，它们主要迎合那些更富裕的人群，这些顾客想要花一天时间沿河漫步，顺便买一副400美元的太阳镜，然后去买古董。劳伦斯画廊（Lawrence gallery）的销售也多多少少依赖这种类型的客户。当时，我们的业务很大程度上依靠散客，也就是那些进店寻找真正特别的礼物并愿意花几百美元的客户。
And I know this sounds like kind of a lot, but it's not like the artist's set or gallery where you're getting rich off of these sales. From what Lauren tells me, it was really mostly just people who wanted to have, you know, like a presence in the local arts community, you know, make their rent at the gallery, and then maybe earn just like a little something extra
我知道这听起来好像挺多的，但并不是说艺术家或画廊能靠这些销售发财。据劳伦告诉我，其实大部分都只是那些想要在当地艺术界有点存在感、付得起画廊房租，然后可能再多赚一点外快的人。
on the side. And for a while, everything was going great. The direction this is going indicates to me that things are not going to be going great soon. And then, okay. So in 2016, Pokemon Go comes out. Oh, okay. Well, that's not what I was expecting. So Pokemon Go comes out. Oh, okay. Well, that's not what I was expecting.
而且有一段时间，一切都很顺利。这个走向对我来说意味着事情很快就不会那么顺利了。然后，好吧。所以在2016年，宝可梦Go（Pokemon Go）上线了。哦，好吧。嗯，这不是我所期待的。所以宝可梦Go上线了。哦，好吧。嗯，这不是我所期待的。
So Pokemon Go comes out. How does that change everything? So have you ever actually played Pokemon Go? I have not played it. I feel like I'm familiar with it a little bit. It's kind of like a augmented reality game where you go find these creatures in the built environment. Pokemon? augmented reality game where you go find these creatures in the built environment. Pokemon. Right. Right. Okay.
所以宝可梦Go上线了。这怎么就改变了一切呢？那么，你真的玩过宝可梦Go吗？我没玩过。我觉得我稍微了解一点。这有点像一个增强现实游戏，你需要在现实环境中去寻找这些生物。宝可梦？增强现实游戏，你需要在现实环境中去寻找这些生物。宝可梦。对。对。好吧。
And then you find, it's like a scavenger hunt on your phone. Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to clarify it just a little bit. Okay. So you're right. It's an augmented reality game. And it's based on your real world locations.
然后你发现，这就像手机上的寻宝游戏。对。对。我稍微澄清一下。好吧。所以你是对的。这是一个增强现实游戏。它是基于你的现实世界位置的。
So you will find things in the game by physically going to those places on the Pokemon Go map. So to capture a Pokemon, or there's these things called PokeStops, where if you go there, you'll get prizes within the game, like Pokeballs and potions and stuff. But you physically have to be at those locations in order to access things within the game.
所以你必须亲自去到宝可梦Go地图上的那些地方才能在游戏中找到东西。为了捕捉宝可梦，或者去那些被称为“宝可斯托普”（PokeStops）的地方，只要你走到那里，就能在游戏里获得奖励，比如精灵球、药水之类的东西。但你必须亲自到达那些位置，才能访问游戏中的内容。
Okay, that makes sense. So it is a way to explore the environment. That's where I remember people walking around parks. Yes, yes, and staring at the phone. I remember the exact day that Pokemon Go came out. And I remember exactly where I was, because this was podcast movement 2016, Chicago. And because the gameplay is based around real-world map data,
好吧，这说得通。所以这是一种探索环境的方式。这就是我记得人们在公园里走来走去的地方。是的，是的，而且盯着手机看。我记得宝可梦Go发布的精确那一天。我也记得我当时确切在哪里，因为那是2016年芝加哥的播客运动（Podcast Movement）大会。因为游戏的玩法是基于现实世界的地图数据的，
usually the best places to play it are, you know, populated cities like Chicago or, you know, like New York. But sometimes these little random places just become hot spots for Pokemon activity, which is exactly what happened in Aquaquan. Aqua Aqua had always been this kind of sleepy town and you would go and it was very comfortable walking around on these picturesque historic streets and it was kind of this very relaxed kind of outing and all of a sudden it was like a river that was far too full to teaming with fish. You know, you just
通常玩这个游戏最好的地方是像芝加哥或纽约这样人口稠密的城市。但有时，这些小小的随机地方也会成为宝可梦活动的热点，这正是奥科昆（Aquiaquan）发生的事情。奥科昆一直是个有点安静的小镇，你可以在这些风景如画的历史街道上悠闲地散步，这是一种非常轻松的远足，而突然之间，它就像一条挤满了鱼、人满为患的河流。你知道，你简直
couldn't walk down the streets. They were so crowded. Wow. And so I can get why New York and Chicago in San Francisco would be hot spots, but how did Alcaquon become Pokemon Central? Yeah, so Pokemon Go was created by this company called Niantic and years earlier, Niantic had come out with this other location-based AR game called Ingris. And I've never played it before, but Ingris' this game were like this mysterious, trans-dimensional force appears, and you as a player have to interact with these portals based on your actual GPS location. So it's kind of a similar concept of using your real-world location to access things within the game. But these portals within Ingress are all based around real-world landmarks.
无法在街上行走。人实在是太多了。哇。所以，我可以理解为什么纽约、芝加哥和旧金山会成为热点，但奥科昆是怎么变成宝可梦中心的呢？是的，宝可梦Go是由一家名为Niantic的公司开发的，几年前，Niantic推出过另一款基于位置的AR游戏叫《Ingress》。我以前没玩过，但《Ingress》这款游戏里会出现一种神秘的、跨维度的力量，作为玩家的你必须根据实际的GPS位置与这些传送门进行互动。所以这和利用现实世界位置来访问游戏内物品的概念有点类似。但《Ingress》中的这些传送门都是围绕现实世界的地标建立的。
And the cool thing about Ingress in particular was that game users could add landmarks to the map within the game. So if you reach a certain level, you can add a historical site or a mural or whatever to the map. So years later, when Niantic teamed up with the Pokemon company to release Pokemon Go, they reused the same map information. And all those portals within In ingress became Pokemon Go Poké Stops. So all those historical sites and even like the certified ghost haunting sites all
《Ingress》特别酷的一点是，游戏用户可以在游戏内的地图上添加地标。因此，如果你达到了某个级别，你就可以将历史遗迹、壁画或任何东西添加到地图上。所以几年后，当Niantic与宝可梦公司合作发布宝可梦Go时，他们重复使用了相同的地图信息。《Ingress》中的所有那些传送门都成了宝可梦Go的“宝可斯托普”。因此，沿途所有的历史遗迹甚至像那些经过认证的闹鬼地点，都
became like Poké Stops along the way. She told me that from like while she was working the gallery from her seat she could access two Poké Stops without ever leaving her chair. Thank goodness for have go. But as you can imagine, this kind of sent the town into a tizzy because it's such a small town and they weren't equipped to handle the sudden influx of people, like walking all over the streets. In the beginning, an enormous pushback. That summer, nothing but pushback.
变成了沿途的“宝可斯托普”。她告诉我，在她画廊工作的期间，从她的座位上，她甚至不需要离开椅子就能访问两个“宝可斯托普”。谢天谢地有“Go”。但正如你所能想象的那样，这让整个小镇陷入了一片混乱，因为这是一个很小的小镇，他们没有能力应对突然涌入的大量人群，比如到处在街上走来走去的人。在最初的时候，遭到了巨大的抵制。那个夏天，到处都是抵制。
But mostly because the residents were like, well, this has got to be, can we just make it illegal? And the town kept on being like, no, no, what? What? A legal for what? What exactly you mean that people should not be allowed to walk on our streets anymore? What exactly are you proposing? And the businesses are like, well, can we like hang signs or something? You can't what? When has a business ever hung a sign saying that a certain contingency of people isn't welcome? Where you thought that possibly history would think that that's okay. Yeah, historically, she's right, historically, that is not a good look. Yeah, historically, she's right. Historically, that is not a good look.
但主要是因为居民们的反应是，这一定是，我们能不能让它违法？而镇上一直说，不，不，什么？什么？为什么违法？你到底是什么意思，说不准人们再走我们的街道了？你到底在提议什么？而商家们则说，好吧，我们能不能挂标语什么的？你不能什么？什么时候有过一家商店挂出标语说某种特定群体的人不受欢迎的？你竟然觉得历史上会认为这没问题。是的，从历史上看，她是正确的，从历史上看，那可真不是个好形象。是的，历史上她是对的。从历史上看，那可真不是个好形象。
No, it's immoral. Okay, so I do remember when Pokemon Go came out that there were these stories of places being inundated with Pokemon Go player, especially trespassing on private property and all that sort of. And what was one, I feel like there was other sort of sacred places or something like that the Holocaust Museum had to be they had to say please Don't play Pokemon go at the Holocaust Museum. Yeah, okay It was yeah, it was a big deal But but I but I if this place is you know kind of meant for a little bit of tourist action
不，这不道德。好吧，我确实记得当宝可梦Go刚出来的时候，有报道说有些地方挤满了宝可梦Go玩家，尤其是擅自闯入私人财产之类的。还有一个，我觉得还有其他一些神圣的地方，比如大屠杀纪念馆（Holocaust Museum）不得不发表声明，请不要在大屠杀纪念馆玩宝可梦Go。是的，好吧。这确实是一件大事。但是，但是，如果这个地方（你知道的）原本是打算吸引一点游客的话，
Is there some way that they could have just capitalized on it and just sold more things or something like that? Yes, and you know, this did happen. Lauren told me that there were businesses that kind of adapted and popped up to like this influx of people, you know, like snack shops would appear and, you know, tourist traps, souvenir type Pokemon Go theme businesses. And she even said that there was a Pokemon Go cruise that opened up that would take you across the Alcacone River at just the right speed
有没有什么办法让他们顺势利用一下，多卖点东西之类的呢？是的，你知道，这确实发生了。劳伦告诉我，有些企业确实适应了这种人流的涌入并应运而生，比如小吃店出现了，旅游陷阱、纪念品类型的宝可梦Go主题企业也出现了。她甚至说，有一艘宝可梦Go游船开张了，它能以刚好合适的航速带你穿过奥科昆河，
so you could hit all the Poke stops. But if you remember, Alcacone was this place that was known for this kind of upscale shopping. And the people who are going to Alcacone to play a video game aren't gonna like drop in and buy an antique clock. Okay, so they had the ability to kind of like take advantage of a bunch of bougie rich people, but they didn't have the ability to take advantage of ten year olds with eye bones glued to their face.
这样你就能打卡所有的“宝可斯托普”了。但如果你还记得的话，奥科昆是一个以高端购物而闻名的可以说是这样的地方。那些去奥科昆玩电子游戏的人是不会顺便进去买一个古董时钟的。好吧，他们有能力去利用一群有钱的资产阶级，但他们却没有能力利用那些把iPhone粘在脸上的十岁小孩。
We don't know what to do in these children. They're not buying antique clocks these kids today. Yeah, but like not only were the children not buying antique clocks, because of all this foot traffic, it was the Pokemon Go players were pretty much driving away at the regular clientele, who helped pay the bills, because you know, you go to a place like Aquaquan for the quiet vibe, and you know, the historic feel, and all of a sudden, it's just teaming with a bunch of people on their iPhones.
我们不知道该拿这些孩子怎么办。现在的孩子们不买古董时钟。是的，但不仅是孩子们不买古董时钟，因为所有这些步行人流，宝可梦Go的玩家基本上把那些帮助付账单的常规客户给赶跑了，因为你知道，你去像奥科昆这样地方是为了那里的安静氛围和历史感，而突然之间，那里挤满了拿着iPhone的人。
So yeah, it became kind of a big issue for the residents. Not only were we not seeing people in the gallery, the wealthy residents weren't shopping in their neighborhood anymore period. And we have this huge influx of people. And instead of revitalizing the town, it completely destroyed commerce. In this shift in business,
所以，是的，这成了当地居民的一个大问题。不仅在画廊里看不到人，富裕的居民也不再来他们社区购物了。我们迎来了大量的人流。但它并没有让小镇焕发活力，反而彻底摧毁了商业。这种商业上的转变，
eventually trickled down into Lauren's artwork, because people were coming in wine to spend around 20 to 40 bucks. So some of the artists at the gallery started making things that were smaller and cheaper and just generally more palatable to more people, and Lauren found herself doing the same thing. My artwork has always been weird and contemporary and often creepy and I was bringing in stuff that was more kind of homogenously whimsical and relatable to more people. And I think just, you know, more boring.
最终也渗透到了劳伦的艺术创作中，因为人们进来时只想花20到40美元左右。因此，画廊里的一些艺术家开始制作更小、更便宜、而且总的来说更能迎合更多大众口味的东西，劳伦发现自己也在做同样的事情。我的艺术作品一直都是怪异的、当代的，而且常常令人毛骨悚然，而我带进来的东西却变得更具同质化的异想天开，更容易引起更多人的共鸣。而且我认为，你知道，就是更无聊了。
It wasn't serving my art at all. I announced that I was going to leave a couple of months ago. And January was my last month that I was at the gallery. Huh. The things go back to the way they were. I mean, like so in Pokemon Go, you know, like it was a big deal a few years ago. It definitely feels like it's, you know, dwindled. Are people still flooding the streets like it was in 2016 that's all started?
这根本无益于我的艺术创作。几个月前我宣布我要离开。一月是我在画廊工作的最后一个月。哈。事情会回到以前的样子吗？我的意思是，比如在宝可梦Go中，你知道的，几年前这是一件大事。现在感觉它确实，你知道的，已经衰落了。人们还在像2016年刚开始那样涌上街头吗？
Yeah, you know, I think a lot of people in town thought that this was just going to be like a little blip on the radar too, but those core clients disappeared. And because of that, the stores that catered to those core clients disappeared too. And I'm not gonna say that aquaquon is like any worse or better than before, but this one game really disrupted the town enough that it changed it on a permanent scale. Right.
是的，你知道，我觉得镇上的很多人以为这只是雷达屏幕上的一个小插曲，但那些核心客户消失了。正因为如此，迎合那些核心客户的商店也消失了。我并不是说奥科昆变得比以前更糟或更好，但这个游戏确实对这个小镇造成了足够的干扰，以至于永久性地改变了它。对。
And since Niantic reused the ingress maps for Pokemon Go, if there's a new game using that same engine, it's going to happen again, right? Yeah, and they actually have reused the same maps for different apps that weren't as popular as Pokemon Go. But theoretically, they could make something as popular if not more popular than Pokemon Go, and then they're going to be in another cycle again. Yeah. I mean, it's sort of an amazing phenomenon that you could sort of create a digital map that has so much effect on the real world. It's kind of a strange amount of power we're giving augmented reality that I've never
既然Niantic为宝可梦Go重复使用了《Ingress》的地图，如果有一款使用相同引擎的新游戏，这种情况还会再次发生，对吧？是的，事实上他们已经在那些不如宝可梦Go受欢迎的不同应用中重复使用了相同的地图。但从理论上讲，他们可以制作出与宝可梦Go一样受欢迎甚至更受欢迎的东西，然后他们又会陷入另一个周期。是的。我的意思是，这真是一个惊人的现象，你可以创造出一张对现实世界产生如此大影响的数字地图。我们赋予增强现实这种程度的力量可以说是相当奇怪的，我以前从未
thought of before. Yeah, yeah. It's like, how do you really regulate something like that? I mean, I mean, I'm probably the answer, because you can't and you probably shouldn't. But a map can really change the meaning of a place. It also just like makes you realize that, you know, like a map for one thing isn't a map for everything. So like reusing these historic sites as,
想过这一点。是的，是的。就像，你到底该如何监管这样的东西？我的意思是，我的答案可能是，因为你做不到，也可能不应该这样做。但一张地图确实能改变一个地方的意义。这也让人意识到，你知道，一张用于某一个目的的地图并不适用于所有事情。所以，把这些历史遗迹重新用作，
you know, popular destinations for cartoon characters. I wonder what it is. I can't. She has her head in her hands. That's God. But like we're using like, you know, these historic markers for things that there are game is like, you know, obviously the Holocaust Museum isn't the place for Pokemon, you know, but both things should exist in the world.
你知道的，卡通角色的热门目的地。我不知道这是什么。我受不了了。她双手抱头。天哪。但是，就像我们重新利用（你知道的）这些历史标记来做游戏的事情一样，（你知道的）显然大屠杀纪念馆不是玩宝可梦的地方，（你知道的）但这两样东西都应该在这个世界上存在。
Pokemon Go should exist in the world. It should. It's done a lot of great things. So I just wanted to give a special thanks to Lauren Jacobs, who I spoke with for the piece, and also to Alistair Sticco, who is actually the one who wrote to us and made sure that we knew about this story. So thank you, Alistair. Nice. Cool. And if you want to see Lauren Jacobs' self-described creepy art, where can they go? We'll have a link to it on our website.
宝可梦Go应该在这个世界上存在。它确实应该。它做了很多伟大的事情。所以我只想特别感谢劳伦·雅各布斯（Lauren Jacobs），我在采访中和她聊过，还有阿利斯泰尔·斯蒂科（Alistair Sticco），实际上正是他写信给我们，确保我们了解了这个故事。所以谢谢你，阿利斯泰尔。很好。很酷。如果你想看劳伦·雅各布斯自称令人毛骨悚然的艺术作品，他们可以去哪里？我们会在我们的网站上提供一个链接。
That's awesome. Thanks, baby. Thank you. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Chris Baroube, Kurt Colstead, Joe Rosenberg, and Vivian Le. Sean Real wrote all the music including this Pokemon song. Kavie Mingle is our senior producer. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Emmith Fitzgerald, Avery Truffaner, Sheree Fuser, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
太棒了。谢谢，宝贝。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》（99% Invisible）由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和维维安·勒（Vivian Le）制作。肖恩·里尔（Sean Real）创作了所有的音乐，包括这首宝可梦之歌。卡维·明格尔（Kavie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、埃米斯·菲茨杰拉德（Emmith Fitzgerald）、埃弗里·特鲁法纳（Avery Truffaner）、谢里·菲瑟（Sheree Fuser）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
Special thanks to the radio topiodoners who make everything redo possible, including Alexander Kandiba, Curtis Galawai, Peter Lines Photography, Paul King, Steph Weaver, and Anil Kondigath. We are a project of 9.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. You cannot find it on a map. You can find beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
特别感谢广播乌托邦（Radio Topia）的捐赠者们，他们让这一切重现成为可能，包括亚历山大·坎迪巴（Alexander Kandiba）、柯蒂斯·加拉威（Curtis Galawai）、彼得·莱恩斯摄影（Peter Lines Photography）、保罗·金（Paul King）、斯特夫·韦弗（Steph Weaver）和阿尼尔·孔迪加斯（Anil Kondigath）。我们是旧金山9.7 K-A-L-W项目的一部分，制作于“广播街”（Radio Row）。你在地图上找不到它。你可以在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心找到美丽的地方。99%无形是PRX旗下广播乌托邦的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。
Fun mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org, on Instagram and read it too. But if you want to suggest a story about maps, even if you want to leave a link to the Peter's Projection scene from the West Wing, I know you've been dying to do it. You can leave a comment at 99pyon.org. 4.0-5.1 4.0-5.1 4.0-5.1
趣玩网站 radiotopia.fm。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，也可以在节目账号@99PI org、Instagram和Reddit上找到我们。但是如果你想建议一个关于地图的故事，哪怕你想留下一个链接到《白宫风云》（West Wing）中彼得投影（Peter's Projection）的场景，我知道你一直渴望这么做。你可以在99pyon.org留下评论。4.0-5.1 4.0-5.1 4.0-5.1
4.0-5.1 4.0-5.1 Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
4.0-5.1 4.0-5.1 广播乌托邦。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。